[Music]
this morning on a special Cinco DeMayo
edition of the dish chef Eddie Hernandez
is here growing up in Mexico he opened
his own food stand just when he was 15
years old his many careers have included
rock and roll drummer let me talk to you
after this Eddie we need a drummer in
our band
Hans here firemen and small town man now
his focus is back on food as executive
chef and partner of George's taqueria
del Sol restaurants his food philosophy
is summed up in his brand-new cookbook
turnip greens and tortillas a Mexican
chef spices up the southern kitchen and
chef Eddie Hernandez again here with us
good morning welcome to the dish
thank you for having me I am a regular
ha Carrillo del Sol when I'm in Atlanta
but tell us what we have here it's go
this is like a typical think of the
Meyer spread that we do you know we got
the grill meeting of the Childress car
with the chimichurri we love to have
pickle eggs take bread and butter
pickles and roasted vegetables
obviously chili again we're gonna have
that insult us of course we can't live
with that such a fantastic drink as well
as I dropped my fork all over the place
how about that does it can with the dry
it's called any polymer because what it
is is the Kentucky Derby
I was watching the movie and they in one
of the writers said any moments are no
problem it's what everybody and I go I'm
gonna use that laughs your love of
cooking in your you started cooking a
lot of that came from your grandmother
shell oh my my talking you got core name
right yeah that's what everybody called
her she was that wonderful woman
excellent cook and the funny thing is
like she'd never get any training she
just cook whatever she wanted she loved
the girl her own best of us you said
there were no chefs just cooks that's
great I mean I think everybody you know
cherish appetite or I don't know where
that came about but we'll just cooks you
know and I grew up believing that I
being a cookie which is something that
you do you know if you want to fend for
yourself you needed to learn how to cook
right well you also when you turned up
in the United States your $2,000 in your
what were you gonna do with that $2,000
I was gonna bring $200 a night what the
boots right and I was gonna figure out
what I was gonna do with my life and
then what happened I didn't finish it
without you did three days into the
saying I made my clink ooh it's my
business partner and my life is changed
right there you but you came here to be
a drummer right yeah in 1974 I went to
Houston and we had a chance to talk to a
recording label the end and I wanted to
be a big rock star and travel the world
it said the talent was not as bigger
than being back right back in the
kitchen and so and so you you the title
of the book is so interesting because
turnip greens factors into your story
somebody came to you with a basket of
turnip greens and said do something with
this yeah it was a name but named Bobby
Avery who was won over for US customers
in 1987 and he says you can make these
things better so I did but the first bag
went to waste because I didn't know what
to do it right I didn't know what they
were so you know what they work he's not
having me I actually went to Mike and
says what is this okay what did you do
with it he gave me a mission three
places in and fire and I figured it out
what they were doing and then I decided
to do it the way I would cook him if I
was in Mexico mmm and changing it's why
everything tastes so good because there
is that Mexican touch in all of it I'm
gonna have a little bit of this Mexican
I'm gonna have you sign our dish and as
I do I'll ask you if you could have a
meal with anyone past or present who
would it be
thus two persons that I will have a meal
with and that's my mom and my grandma
both of them who raised you who you grew
up with and helped bring us all of this
yes chef Eddie Hernandez thank you so
much thank you for me I want more on
chef Eddie Hernandez and the dish you
can head to our website CBS this morning
calm